le mentalisme sur Internet c'est bien
mais en vrai c'est mieux je reviens sur
scène avec mon nouveau spectacle qui
mélange comme toujours humour mentalisme
et science je joue à Paris au Palais des
Glaces pour seulement 18 représentations
puis le spectacle fera sa première
tournée avec des dates en France
Belgique Suisse jusqu'en juin 2h de show
ça va être un délire salut bienvenue
dans ce nouvel épisode d'une histoire à
la pierre Bellemare la mode est au trade
alors nous on fait les Old trade les
anciennes histoires sur des personnes
aujourd'hui pour célébrer Halloween qui
va venir on va pour une fois faire
quelque chose d'un petit peu plus d'un
petit peu plus sombre on va parler d'un
prétendu sorcier qui aurait mieux fait
d'être un sorcier au final donc pas de
panique ça fait pas vraiment peur mais
on est dans la thématique d'Halloween
pour vous situer imaginez qu'on est en
Mayenne dans le dans la région de Laval
et que ça se passe en 1926 il y a moins
de 100 ans il va se passer des
événements là-bas qui au-delà de leur
côté incroyable et intéressant vont
permettre d'ajouter ma petite analyse et
de vous orienter aussi sur le sujet qui
devrait vous plaire alors un prétendu
sorcier qui était pas vraiment sorcier
mais quand même mieux fait de l'être
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire je raconte
tout ça après une vérité presque nickel
oui on a un partenaire aujourd'hui il a
quelque chose à nous apprendre bienvenue
dans les dossiers du Nord des vérités
presque nickel oui les dossiers du Nord
VPN sponsorisé par Nord VPN aujourd'hui
nous allons découvrir la vérité sur
Victor Hugo le grand secret qui lui a
permis d'écrire Notre-Dame de Paris
alors qu'il n'était même pas à Paris et
oui c'est ça la vérité Victor et
l'inventeur du télétravail il n'a jamais
vécu en France pour écrire son livre il
faisait des recherches sur la cathédrale
en utilisant nordvpn de VPN le plus
rapide du marché le plus simple
d'utilisation avec sa connexion
automatique pour pallier au manque
d'inspiration Victor changeait souvent
de pays plus malin que une gargouille il
changeait son IP pour se connecter sur
les sites de réservation de tels et
profiter de prix réduit grâce à leur VPN
et toujours avec nordvpn Victor il
regardait depuis l'étranger des
documentaires français sur la cathédrale
qu'il n'avait du coup jamais visité je
m'emballe mais sachez qu'il a pu
sécuriser sa connexion sur les wifi
public heureusement
imaginez un bug il fichier Notre-Dame de
paris.pdf effacez bon après ça aurait
fait moins de choses à réviser pour le
bac si vous cherchez un VPN alors faites
comme cette illustre auteur qui avait
cliqué sur le lien dans ma description
pour bénéficier de l'offre actuelle
Victor a même précisé dans une préface
de l'univers que si vous n'étiez pas
satisfait en 30 jours vous seriez
remboursé merci nordvpn et à bientôt
pour une nouvelle vérité presque nickel
je vous l'ai dit nous sommes faire Laval
en Mayenne en 1926 dans un tout petit
village dans ce village il y a juste une
église à peine une vingtaine de maisons
qui sont autour et après dispatcher un
petit peu partout quelques fermes c'est
un village plutôt refermé c'est un
village paysan les gens se fréquentent
pas vraiment le seul moment où il se
voit c'est après la messe le dimanche
mais ils ont pas tellement
d'interactions entre le reste du temps
c'est ce qu'on appelle un peu des
taiseux c'est des gens qui sont un peu
repliés sur eux-mêmes le village
d'ailleurs vide principalement en
autonomie sans trop contact avec les
autres villages et les grandes villes
tout le monde ici travaille dans les
champs tout le monde non
pas Joseph Joseph Martin 78 ans ne
travaille pas et pour cause il est à la
retraite à la base il était
fonctionnaire à Laval et il s'est
installé ici en 1913 donc 13 ans avant
il s'est installé seul avec son chien et
évidemment puisque c'est pour ça
retraite il bosse pas mais il a jamais
bossé dans les chambres ou en tant
qu'adriculteur il fait pas partie
vraiment de la même mentalité que ce
village ici tout le monde l'appelle le
père Martin c'est la personne qu'on
croise le plus facilement comme il
travaille pas dans les champs il peut un
petit peu se balader il va à l'église
également le dimanche évidemment et
après c'est une personnalité comme on en
connaît tous il râle en permanence il se
plaint de tout c'est un homme très
pessimiste alors est-ce que c'est pour
ça qu'il est seul ou est-ce parce qu'il
est seul qui râle tout le temps on sait
pas est-ce qu'il y a une histoire
derrière tout ça on sait pas non plus le
fait que c'est le genre de personne que
tu croises il a toujours un truc très
désagréable à dire du style il va grêler
la semaine prochaine ça va tuer toute la
récolte de session ah non là on va avoir
un hiver qui va être horrible on n'aura
jamais assez de bois pour se chauffer
non non là faut pas s'attendre à ce qui
se fasse beau demain pour la messe non
il va pleuvoir c'est sûr donc il y a
toujours des trucs comme ça si il y a un
animal qui malade il dit qu'il y a une
épidémie et que toutes les bêtes vont
mourir par exemple donc il prédit
toujours qui va arriver quelque chose de
vraiment pas cool sauf que hasard de la
vie une fois sur deux on va dire quand
il dit quelque chose qui va mal se
passer cette chose là se passe mal quand
il va pleuvoir dimanche bah une fois sur
deux il pleut dimanche mais c'est pas
parce qu'il est fin météorologue ou
parce qu'il est voyant c'est juste il a
le jeté une pièce en l'air sur la météo
du côté pessimiste et oui ça arrive
qu'il pleuve les dimanches sauf qu'à
force qui disent des choses qui
s'avèrent être vrai le cerveau est ainsi
fait il se rappelle en fait des des
choses qui ont été justement prédis
c'est d'ailleurs une des manières pour
lesquelles les personnes qui de voyance
parfois se font des réputations parce
que on se souvient de leur bonne
prédiction on en parle beaucoup après
mais on se souvient pas de toutes les
fois où ils ont pas eu bon en fait c'est
juste que la pièce est tombée du bon
côté une fois de temps en temps pour le
père Martin du coup le village et les
habitants se souvient toujours de MSA il
avait dit ça il avait dit il commence à
trouver ça un peu bizarre est-ce qu'il
l'avait dit est-ce qu'il l'avait
pressenti où est-ce qu'il nous avait
prévenu qu'il allait faire en sorte que
ça arrive on se dit qu'il est bizarre ce
père Martin parce que il a jamais eu de
terre ici au final il avait pas de
famille il a jamais travaillé dans les
champs il a jamais travaillé à la ferme
qu'est-ce qui fait ici pourquoi il est
venu s'installer ici et pas ailleurs et
vous voyez le genre des questions qui
peut comme ça
s'auto alimenter dans la rumeur et
gangrener un peu tous les esprits et
d'ailleurs les villageois se demandent
de quoi il vit comment il fait pour se
nourrir c'est quoi ces ressources et
bien il y a une conclusion très simple
qui tombe avec lesquels tout le village
est d'accord c'est que Joseph Martin est
un sorcier c'est un jeteur de sort et la
rumeur fait son œuvre mais quand je dis
que la rumeur fait son œuvre c'est qu'il
y a des histoires qui commencent à
apparaître et être à compter des
souvenirs des anecdotes par exemple une
des histoires raconte que Joseph Martin
s'arrête chez des voisins à lui pour
faire une pause sur sa route il s'assoit
près du berceau de l'enfant il boit un
coup il repart juste après l'enfant a
des coliques néphrétiques coliques
tellement violentes qu'elles ont failli
tuer l'enfant heureusement les parents
ont su s'occuper de lui à tous les coups
c'est les sorcières il y a une autre
histoire qui raconte que quand il passe
près d'un champ où il y a des bêtes des
vaches ou n'importe quel autre animaux
et bien les animaux se mettent à danser
très bizarrement c'est de la sorcellerie
c'est de l'autocréation de légende ça on
y reviendra plus tard dans la vidéo vous
allez voir c'est très intéressant
psychologiquement et il y a eu une
expérience qui a été menée il quelques
années qui est fascinante je vous en
reparlerai un peu plus tard on va suivre
l'histoire du Bernardin parce que
maintenant on a donc un village qui
possède un sorcier de 78 ans qui ne fait
que des catastrophes partout il passe
volontairement ça nous amène au 4
septembre 1926 Joseph Martin se réveille
il se lève et un petit peu beau temps il
se dit c'est un temps à les cueillir des
noisettes donc il va aller dans un bois
un bois qui lui appartient pas ça c'est
vrai mais c'est un bois où tout village
va depuis toujours pour aller cueillir
des noisettes c'est autorisé il y a pas
de problème le bois appartient à la
famille Benoît donc le chemin le plus
court pour Joseph pour aller de chez lui
jusqu'au bois des Benois c'est de
traverser le champ et Lefebvre et c'est
ce qui fait sauf qu'arrivée dans le
champ il y a Gustave Lefebvre qui est
dans son champ et qui dit NON NON
interdiction de passer il le regarde
comme ça il dit vous ne passerez pas
avec un bâton et tout non évidemment il
lui donne juste l'interdiction de passer
et Joseph Martin compr pas trop il dit
en fait je vais juste au bois des Benois
pour aller chercher des noisettes et
Gustave et non non non vous passez pas
parce que vous allez me jeter un sort là
c'est sûr vous allez me faire du mal
vous me menacez en fait Martin comprend
pas trop ce qui se passe il se dit que
l'autre a un peu perdu peut-être la
boule il veut pas d'ennuis donc il fait
demi-tour il se dit ben je vais prendre
un chemin qui est beaucoup plus long
mais au moins j'ai pas d'ennuis avec
l'un de mes voisins et voilà c'est ce
qui fait sauf que la Gustave lui il sait
que Joseph va aller au bois des Benois
du coup il part chez les propriétaires
du bois forcément il est plus rapide
déjà parce qu'il est plus jeune que
Martin mais lui il a le raccourci alors
que Joseph fait le grand tour Gustave
arrive chez les Benoît juste avant
d'arriver devant chez eux ils tombent
sur Jeannette une jeune femme de 20 ans
très robuste qui est en train de sortir
les vaches pour les emmener auprès et là
il a prévient il a prévient qu'il vit à
venir pour voler le bétail peut-être le
tuer anéantir les récoltes en tout cas
il arrive effectivement Joseph arrive
le chemin devant Jeannette qui est
persuadé qui veut venir maudire sa ferme
et son bois elle lui dit non non vous ne
passez pas vous vous allez jeter un sort
à mes vaches vous allez vous allez
maudire mon bois non non vous passez pas
du tout Joseph Martin s'explique il dit
pas du tout je veux de mal à personne je
veux juste chercher des noisettes
regardez vos vaches sont là je suis là
elles n'ont pas l'air d'avoir peur tout
se passe bien sauf que pas de bol pour
lui au moment où il dit ça une des
vaches se met à meublé et un veau se met
à sautiller mais alors à ceiller c'est
pas c'est pas normal c'est les veaux ils
sont jeunes ils sont joueurs sauf que
elle Jeannette ça l'a fait voir rouge en
fait dis il a commencé il a commencé il
vient de jeter un sort il fait danser
mes vaches le fameux il fait danser les
animaux elle panique alors elle prend
son bâton c'est un gros gourdin et elle
frappe un grand coup à la tête Joseph
Martin il s’écroule au sol hyper
connaissance immédiatement elle elle
continue de taper avec tout ce ramdam
les deux frères de Jeannette arrivent
voilà donc qu'est-ce qu'ils font ils
continuent de taper Joseph Martin qui
est au sol donc vraiment il est passé à
ta base c'est très dur et puis bah au
bout d'un moment il faut bien emmener
les vaches pâturées donc les trois
emmènent les vaches et laisse Joseph
Martin ici en l'état il le laisse pour
mort Joseph Martin se réveille il fait
déjà nuit il fait même une nuit très
avancée parce qu'on est presque au matin
il a la jambe droite qui est cassée il
sait pas encore ce qu'il a d'autre mais
il a mal partout il comprend mal ce qui
s'est passé et il sait qu'il peut pas
rester là ça va ça va pas aller pour lui
il peut pas rentrer jusqu'à chez lui
donc il se dit je vais aller à la ferme
la plus proche c'est celle des leviers
et il va là-bas littéralement en rampant
parce qu'il peut pas se tenir debout
c'est pas possible il rentre tant bien
que mal il souffre malheureusement
beaucoup il arrive devant la ferme dès
le lièvres et devant la ferme Raymond
Lelièvre et déjà sorti il est déjà
réveillé il est déjà le veille il est en
train de travailler sur son tas de
fumier tout simplement et il voit Joseph
Martin le père Martin arrivait comme ça
ensanglanté en rampant jusqu'à lui tant
bien que mal Joseph arrive jusqu'au
billet de Raymond il lui explique tout
ce qui s'est passé évidemment tout lui
est revenu quand même et dans quel état
il s'est réveillé qu'il a besoin d'aide
absolument tout de suite et Raymond lui
dit alors père Martin tu as qu'à te
servir de tes pouvoirs tu as pas besoin
de moi pour t'aider tu sais là tes
petits pouvoirs tes petits sœurs là
comme quand tu nous poses des problèmes
en permanence et que tu crées des
catastrophes autour de nous que tu
abîmes les récoltes le père Martin
explique que tout ça est faux que ce
sont des racontars des ragots des
rumeurs sur lui qu'il a jamais eu de
pouvoir et la femme et le fils de
Raymond arrive à ce moment-là le fils de
Raymond Gaston voit le père Martin comme
ça au sol pour lui c'est sûr c'est un
sorcier maléfique sa mauvaise home et il
s'apprête du coup à lui donner un coup
de pied au niveau des côtes et il arrête
de son pied juste avant les côtes parce
qu'il a peur que son pied se brise parce
que ça fait partie des légendes qu'on
raconte sur le père Martin que si tu le
frappes avec un bâton le bâton s'envole
que si tu essayes de le frapper alors
ton bras peut se casser donc il a très
peur de ça mais son père Raymond rassure
son fils Gaston en lisant non non tu
peux y aller c'est bon il a perdu ses
pouvoirs apparemment c'est terrible de
se dire ça mais à l'époque les croyances
sont beaucoup plus fortes qu'aujourd'hui
les trois en même temps
mettent une deuxième volet à Martin Le
Rue de coup de nouveau le passe à tabac
alors la femme de Raymond le frappa avec
un bâton qui ne s'envole pas le fils de
Raymond Gaston le frappe ses jambes ne
casse pas et donc là il le laisse de
nouveau comme ça pour moi parce qu'on
est dimanche et que les trois partent à
la messe c'est vraiment très bizarre de
se dire allez on va vraiment attaquer un
homme on lui fait le plus de mal
possible puis après ben on fait ce qu'on
a à faire on laisse là quoi la messe se
passe et à la sortie de la messe tout le
monde se retrouve et comme je vous
disais au début de la vidéo c'est le
moment où tout le monde discute un petit
peu se raconte ce qu'il a à se raconter
les choses de la semaine les choses de
la vie se demandent des conseils ou des
services et les Benoît comme les
Lelièvre raconte un petit peu ce qu'ils
ont vécu avec le père Martin et la
rumeur faisant encore son affaire c'est
même plus de sorciers qu'il le traitent
ils disent que c'est le diable et donc
ils sont très fiers d'eux parce qu'ils
disent qu'ils ont neutralisé le diable
alors tout le monde s'étonne que il
reçoit pas arrivé une grande malédiction
en essayant de de frapper le diable le
père Martin mais les Benoit comme le
lièvre expliquent que tout va bien il a
perdu ses pouvoirs c'est bon il y a de
la cryptonite ou un truc comme ça quand
le maire entend ça parce qu'il est à la
messe lui aussi il y croit pas du tout
parce qu'il croit pas du tout en la
sorcellerie il croit pas dans ses
racontars là donc il pense juste que le
père Martin est un humain comme
n'importe quel être humain qui peut
appeler cette planète et du coup
finement il dit ah donc vous avez
détruit le diable mais vous l'avez
laissé où et Raymond répond qu'il a
laissé au tas de fumier là où il est
venu me voir et là où ils l'ont ils
l'ontralisé donc imagine qu'il doit y a
encore y être ou alors peut-être cette
transformée en verre le maire fonce chez
les Lelièvre à la ferme il va au
tatumier il y a personne il fait un peu
de recherche dans les alentours et dans
un buisson mais un buisson épineux un
buisson d'un tas de rond il trouve à
l'intérieur le père Martin qui qui a dû
essayer de ramper sur mon jusque-là pour
essayer de se sauver sa peau en fait
tout simplement pour pas qu'on le
retrouve encore et qui se repasse encore
la même chose il est inconscient mais le
maire va pouvoir s'occuper de lui parce
qu'il est pas mort c'est ça qui est
incroyable avec tout ce qui vient de
subir en moins de 24 heures il est
toujours vivant et donc le maire va le
transporter directement à l'hôpital
l'Hôtel-Dieu qui se trouve à Laval quand
on lit les rapports du médecin il est
dit que selon le médecin il y a pas un
centimètre de la peau de Joseph Martin
qui ne comporte pas une ecchymose il a
les jambes cassé il a quatre côtes
enfoncé il a le poignet brisé là
également le nez cassé il a un œil crevé
il est dans le coma mais il est toujours
en vie suite à tout ça évidemment le
maire va aller voir les gendarmes pour
raconter tout ce qui s'est passé et le
18 décembre 1927 la famille le lièvre et
la famille Benoît vont passer devant la
Cour de justice plus précisément ils
vont être jugés devant la Cour
correctionnelle et ça c'est un élément
important pourquoi la Cour
correctionnelle et pourquoi pas la cour
d'assise parce que les Benoit et les le
lièvre sont pour le moment jugés pour
couper blessures comme Joseph Martin est
encore dans le coma ils peuvent pas être
jugés pour meurtre mais uniquement pour
Coe blessures aujourd'hui on rajouterait
violence en groupe en réunion je sais
pas si ça existait déjà à cette époque
mais c'est quand même pas du tout le
même type de jugement le lièvre est
interrogé alors il explique il se défend
il dit oui mais je me suis battu contre
le Diable qu'est-ce que je pouvais faire
d'autre il y a le diable qui vient chez
moi il faut bien que je le neutralise et
le juge lui demande s'il avait déjà vu
Joseph Martin pratiquer la sorcellerie
ou ses diableries et le lien vous dit
non non moi je voudrais surtout pas voir
ça jamais de la vie quoi ça pourrait me
traumatiser à vie ça pourrait me dire ma
famille encore heureux je l'ai jamais vu
faire et tout le village du moins les
personnes du village qui sont présentes
au tribunal à ce moment-là soutiennent
très très fort le lièvre je veux dire
c'est pas parce qu'il passe au tribunal
c'est pas parce que Joseph Martin est
dans le coma c'est pas parce que la
justice c'est en parade de ça que ça a
changé leur croyances vis-à-vis de
Joseph Martin ça les a plutôt renforcé
dire que c'est pas un sorcier en fait
c'est le diable et il nous cause que des
ennuis la preuve et l'avocat dès le
lièvre et des Benois en toute cohérence
avec ce qui vient de se raconter va
plaider pour ses clients donc encore une
fois des personnes qui ont tabassé
Joseph Martin il va plaider la légitime
défense de ces deux familles parce que
si c'est le diable qui arrive ils se
sont juste défendus contre le Diable
donc légitime défense ballon c'est
courageuse c'est courageux d'avoir tenu
une tête aux forces du mal et ça a pas
trop mal fonctionné les deux familles
ont pris six mois de prison
avec sursis c'est
[Musique]
cette histoire donc elle est incroyable
pour Joseph Martin évidemment mais je
voudrais juste revenir sur un point de
la vidéo c'est l'analyse psychologique
de tout ça de comment cette rumeur a pu
vraiment prendre comment ça se fait
qu'il y a des gens qui racontent des
histoires qui qui ont l'air vrai qu'ils
ont l'air d'avoir vécu et qui
soutiennent d'ailleurs avoir vécu avec
Joseph Martin pratiquant de la
sorcellerie ou leurs jetant des sorts ça
me fait beaucoup penser à une sorte de
de documentaire qui avait fait des red
brown qui s'appelle le secret de la
chance the secret of luck on peut le
trouver sur Youtube je vous mettrai un
lien dans la description si vous voyez
cette vidéo sur Youtube parce que je
crois que ça dure une trentaine de
minutes mais c'est assez passionnant en
fait derrière moi on a voulu démontrer
justement comment la rumeur passait
psychologiquement par plein de biais
cognitifs et par système des faux
souvenirs je vous raconte rapidement
comment il a fait il est allé dans le
village
avec une équipe de reporters et de
journalistes qui sont allés interroger
plein de gens dans nos villages à propos
d'une statue c'était une statue de chien
qui a dans le village que personne
connaît vraiment il y en a qui savent
qu'Allah
et les journalistes interrogaient les
habitants pour savoir s'ils
connaissaient la légende donc de du
chien de la chance parce que la légende
raconte que si quand on passe à côté de
la statue on tape sur la tête du chien
ou qu'on le caresse ça porte chance et
donc ils ont fait tout le tour du
village avec ça en demandant voilà aux
gens s'ils avaient des souvenirs avec sa
qui leur avait raconté cette histoire
etc etc etc cette histoire n'a jamais
existé c'est une invention des
journalistes et de Daren Brown ce
jour-là le jour du reportage ils ont
comme semé une graine dans l'esprit de
toutes ces personnes ils sont revenus
quelques mois plus tard
[Musique]
et à force de s'auto-alimenter on
commence à créer des imaginaires de tout
ça et ces imaginaires sont transposées
dans la mémoire épisodique des personnes
et deviennent des vrais faux souvenirs
mais la personne est sincère quand elle
raconte c'est malheureusement je pense
qu'il s'est passé pour Joseph Martin
c'était le quatrième épisode des trades
à la Belle-Mare des hold trade j'espère
que ça vous a plu dites moi dans les
commentaires ce que vous en avez pensé
c'est un peu plus dark pour coller un
petit peu la thématique d'Halloween de
la semaine prochaine je sais pas si vous
fêtez Halloween est-ce que les gens en
fait encore halloween c'est une vraie
question ça moi je sais où je serai pour
Halloween je serai je serai sur scène
puisque mon spectacle le nouveau
spectacle a commencé la semaine dernière
au Palais des Glaces j'y suis pour
seulement 18 représentations donc ils
doivent rester 16 si je dis pas de
bêtises et après je serai en tournée où
je fais toutes les villes en France en
Belgique en Suisse vous avez tout ça
sûrement qui s'affiche devant moi et
puis je vous mettrai un lien dans la
description le mentalisme sur Internet
c'est bien le mentalisme en vrai c'est
mieux venez voir certaines ce que ça
rend merci beaucoup à nordvpn d'avoir
sponsorisé cette vidéo
vous trouverez le lien dans la
description pour bénéficier de l'offre
actuelle prenez soin de vous vérifiez
que vous êtes toujours abonnés on ne
sait jamais vous abonnez vous d'ailleurs
si c'est pas le cas activez la cloche si
vous voulez ne pas rater les prochaines
vidéos prenez soin de vous à très
bientôt Ciao